i don't think you can say enough about
just his ability to digest the game plan
he's kept himself in good shape you know
i know he had the back thing to be able
to come in on such short notice with
such short practice time and to play the
way that he did is uh it was a big boost
to our team for
sure coach sean mcvay after sunday's
huge win over the atlanta falcons and
the debut of jaylen ramsey peter you
were down in atlanta you talked with
people from the rams before the game you
talked to eric weddle after the game
give me the sense of of what you learned
talking to folks about the the
integration of jalen ramsey to a defense
that went to the super bowl last year
well a couple of things mike i mean uh
you know you expect everybody in the
locker room and the coach to say
uh great things about ramsey
you're obviously happy you got him and
he's gonna be a big big piece
on this team the rest of the ways no
denying any of that his first game was
not particularly good he gave up four
catches to julio jones for 69 yards
uh and you know he talked a lot he
screamed at julio jones a lot uh but i i
think he was a little bit rusty quite
frankly
for not having played for the last three
weeks
um
he made that one good play in the in you
know in in forcing the fumble but i
think the rams right now
they're they're pretty they're pretty
convinced at this point
that he is going to be able to adjust to
the kind of combo platter of zone and
man he's going to be asked to play he
only he started the game playing dime
and he only played 36 snaps but that was
a little bit more than at the start of
the game they expected him to play and i
think because it was going so well in
the game itself they said let's
integrate him into other parts of the
defense so i think overall they were
they were happy in getting him obviously
and how he played he was okay but they
certainly expect them to play better
especially against some of the great
receivers on their schedule well it
still was phenomenal i mean for at least
for my money for what he did i mean he
is going to bring an attitude to that
defense we know they're going to be able
to be creative around him because of the
different skills you mentioned peter he
is he's great at zone he's awesome at
man i mean it's him or stefan gilmore
for the best corner in football and
jalen ramsey's just starting the prime
of his career but you know even though
yeah it wasn't his best game
every team in football will sign up for
four for 63 yards with a corner that's
on the island against julio jones and
that's what i'm amazed by and i know it
wasn't his best but man to not play
three in three weeks and then to be able
to go out there and just go oh yeah let
me guard the freakiest one of the
freakiest athletes we've seen on the
history of the planet here and uh i'll
be okay and be able to hold my own i
think it just speaks to the talent level
the guy does have and it's really cool
the rams what they got wade phillips has
got some toys as far as him and aaron
donald that he can really play with and
stress offenses out with
hey peter how surprised were you that
the rams didn't sign him to an extension
on the way through the door that's a lot
to give up it gives him a lot of
leverage i saw a report over the weekend
that the rams extracted a promise from
ramsey that he won't hold out next year
well that's worthless and unenforceable
i would have preferred getting a deal
done now because it's going to be more
expensive later and he's going to be
able to sit back and say nope that's not
good enough give me more
jalen ramsey was not going to do that
the only way you were going to be able
to trade for jalen ramsey is to take his
contract as is as you say mike with a
tacit
uh unenforceable agreement that he's not
going to hold out next year in fact i
will be shocked if he holds out next
year uh and and i believe he is
determined to play
uh that last year of his contract the
reason i'd be shocked is because it's
been pretty common knowledge that if you
trade for uh jalen ramsey
he wanted out of jacksonville so bad
that he basically will sign somewhere
and stay there for a year and a half
and mike i think if
somehow some way he holds out next july
in august
i think it's going to have a
significantly deleterious effect on his
market value because now he basically
went on strike against the jacksonville
jaguars and then he he totally misled a
team willing to throw him the safety net
and to get him out of jacksonville
knowing that what other place in the nfl
that's willing to pay as much
compensation would a player rather go to
than los angeles particularly right los
angeles in year one
of one of the best stadiums
that's ever been built on planet earth
so i i disagree with all of that i
disagree with peter i gotta throw the
challenge flag i disagree with all that
first of all it's 1.3 state income tax
in california and secondly the guys
already faked a back injury for three
weeks holding out in july and august is
nothing compared to that and aaron
donald did it for two straight years in
order to get his market value deal
that's the thing with the rankings
aaron donald did not go on strike and
miss games okay
aaron donald he he held out but he
didn't report
play
and then miss games when he wasn't hurt
you know that that's there's a big
difference between what aaron donald did
and what jalen ramsey ramsay as long as
he's still the best corner in the game
there's going to be a market for jalen
ramsey and someone's going to be happy
to pay him no matter whether he holds
out next year or not
wasting your breath they're going to pay
him they'll be there they're going to
pay him
all right we have decided to continue
the discussion we were having about the
jaylen ramsey contract
possibility with the rams or with
someone else peter i think it was in
your court to uh to take issue with my
belief that none of this is going to
matter that he's eventually going to get
top dollar from someone even if he holds
out next year
mike here's the reason why jalen ramsey
absolutely unequivocally would not have
signed an extension right now it makes
no financial sense to do so for him
first of all the highest paid corners in
the game right now are in the on average
15 million a year range okay
what do you suppose is gonna happen
two years from now when the salary cap
is and let's just estimate it is 25
million dollars a year more
and you play up to your level of
capability i mean if you were to sign an
extension right now let's say and blow
past everybody you know xavier and
howard and i think josh norman you blow
by those guys and you're making 17 or
even 18 million a year i mean
my biggest question is other than just
the insurance of having the guaranteed
money in the contract done if you have
faith in yourself
why wouldn't you choose to be a free
agent potentially
and why wouldn't you do so at a time
when there's a new collected bargaining
agreement that could have this
significant part to it who's to say that
the next cba absolutely is going to have
the franchise tag it will also it
definitely i guarantee you i'll bet you
everything i own that the franchise tag
will be in the next cba
okay that's fine that's fine
even if even if the franchise tag is in
the new cba
there's going to be great advantages to
players who are going to be free agents
signing in 2021
okay because there's going to be a burst
of new money
and also the rams are going it's going
to be incumbent on the rams that you've
got to keep this guy
so for him not to hold out in the new
stadium and all that other stuff he's
going to be looking at in my opinion by
signing in 20
20 21 an average of 20 million dollars a
year there's no way he'd get that now
well but but they still will have the
franchise tag available i'm looking at
from the standpoint of if the rams don't
pay him before next year because i think
he wants to get a contract before next
year i don't buy the idea that holding
out is gonna hurt his value down the
road guys hold out all the time in an
effort to get a better contract so i and
again chris chris's point is none of it
matters because the rams are gonna
eventually pay him anyway yes yes good
work guys good segment you guys keep
going
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports